ronzio puntura fastidio prurito contagio
queste cinque parole ci portano subito
alla mente uno degli animali meno amati
in assoluto la zanzara questo insetto è
poco amato non solo perché noioso e
fastidioso ma soprattutto perché è
vettore virus e protozoi agenti patogeni
in grado di causare gravissime malattie
pensate che tra tutte le specie animali
le zanzare sono quelle che uccidono ogni
anno il maggior numero di persone
addirittura più dell'uomo stesso
a tal proposito vorrei raccontarvi due
brevi storie
la prima riguarda una signora che ho
incontrato alcuni anni fa durante un
attività in campo di monitoraggio che
aveva perso purtroppo il marito di
malaria molti anni prima
mi disse che non avrebbe mai immaginato
che un insetto così piccolo potesse fare
tanto male
la seconda storia invece riguarda
un'altra signora che contrasse alcuni
anni fa due anni fa la febbre tropicale
ciconia mi disse che credeva non sarebbe
mai guarita da quei terribili dolori
articolari che l'hanno tenuto a letto
per mesi più di cinque mesi
questo ci dice quanto il problema delle
zanzare si è diventato attuale e globale
infatti una cosa che vorrei sottolineare
una differenza tra le due storie
riguarda proprio il luogo del contagio
mentre nel primo caso la signora il
marito della signora contrasse la
malaria in africa dove si era recato per
lavoro
nel secondo caso la signora fu punta da
una zanzara tigre infetta in italia a
casa sua sul litorale laziale
questa diciamo diffusione globale delle
zanzare è legata sicuramente al
commercio al traffico e al movimento
delle persone ed è dovuta soprattutto a
delle specie di zanzare dette invasive
come questa qui è una bellissima zanzara
la zanzara tigre ed è salvo pictus ma
altrettanto pericolosa
le zanzare invasive sono zanzare
originarie di aree tropicali quindi del
pianeta ma che si sono adattate a vivere
alla perfezione anche alle nostre
latitudini in questa
in questo video potete vedere una
femmina di ed è salvo pictus intenta a
fare un prelievo di sangue dalla mia
gamba l'anno scorso d'estate questa
zanzara oltre ad essere vettore del
virus c comune a e vettore anche di
altre patologie dengue zica due tra le
tante con le quali dovremo fare sempre
più conti in un prossimo futuro
tutti noi quindi sogniamo un mondo senza
zanzare o almeno senza le patologie da
esse trasmesse
ma come possiamo fare a vincere la
battaglia contro questi insetti che
hanno una capacità di adattamento
straordinaria e che hanno su di noi
esseri umani un vantaggio evolutivo di
milioni di anni
pensate che le prime zanzare sembra
siano comparse sulla terra a 250 milioni
di anni fa
quindi ne hanno viste di tutti i colori
e probabilmente sono in grado di far
fronte a tutte le minacce per loro le
zanzare e così come la maggior parte
degli insetti dannosi è stata sono state
combattute fino ad oggi principalmente
mediante pesticidi chimici sostanze in
qualche modo efficace nel uccidere le
zanzare ed insetti ma anche dannose per
la per la nostra salute per l'ecosistema
infatti si è visto per esempio che
queste sostanze possono eliminare anche
insetti utili quali le api e altri
impollinatori un'alternativa
all'utilizzo dei pesticidi quindi che
sono una risorsa ma anche un problema
può aggiungere dallo studio della
biologia di questi insetti che ha messo
in luce negli ultimi anni importanti
differenze tra maschi e femmine
non so quanti di voi sanno ad esempio
che è solo la femmina di zanzara che ci
punge e che ha bisogno del sangue o
meglio ha bisogno delle proteine
presenti nel sangue per far maturare le
sue uova quindi ne ha bisogno per la sua
riproduzione i maschi di zanzara non
hanno proprio apparato boccale per
pungere si nutrono di fluidi zuccherini
che prendono dei fiori sanno invece fare
un'altra cosa molto
bene sanno individuare le femmine in
campo aperto per potersi accoppiare
riprodurre proprio sfruttando queste
differenze fisiologiche e
comportamentali che hanno le zanzare ma
che sono comuni a tante altre specie di
insetti alcuni anni fa è stata messa a
punto una metodica a basso impatto
ambientale ma ad alto contenuto
tecnologico alternativa ai pesticidi per
fare per combattere gli insetti dannosi
che si chiama tecnica dell'insetto
sterile questa metodica consiste
nell'allevamento massivo quindi in
apposite biofabbrica di un grandissimo
numero di individui della specie che si
vuole combattere con la separazione dei
maschi dalle femmine
la sterilizzazione dei maschi con vari
metodi e il rilascio di questi maschi in
natura questi maschi competono con i
maschi selvatici per l'accoppiamento
ma i loro accoppiamenti non portano al
nuovo progenie quindi all'insaputa delle
femmine che li scelgono questo porta ad
un abbassamento della densità della
popolazione infestante si può arrivare
anche alla totale eradicazione in una
determinata area
nonostante le tecnologie che sono state
prodotte fino ad oggi quindi è il
sistema che è stato sviluppato che ha
funzionato con grande successo per molte
specie di parassiti agricoli per le
zanzare la metodica deve essere ancora
perfezionata
ci sono infatti tre problemi il primo
riguarda proprio la separazione fra i
sessi separare i maschi dalle femmine ma
in un modo che sia automatizzabile su
scala industriale perché deve essere
prodotte milioni di maschi seri parliamo
di 100 milioni di maschi a settimana per
un programma di controllo perché così
importante questo è molto importante per
le zanzare perché le femmine anche se
sterili sono comunque in grado di
trasmettere le malattie e quindi non
possono assolutamente essere rilasciate
in campo
questo rende oggi la tecnica ancora un
po costosa se deve essere applicata su
larga scala il secondo problema riguarda
il luogo dove deve essere applicata
perché mentre per i parassiti agricoli
si lavora in un campo coltivato anche
una un'area omogenea e più facile da
gestire
qui dobbiamo lavorare dove abitiamo noi
dove viviamo noi umani perché noi siamo
in qualche modo una risorsa per le
zanzare
c'è bisogno quindi di agire in modo
capillare sul territorio casa per casa
entrando nelle proprietà private e
questo non è sempre facile
infine c'è bisogno di convincere le
persone che vivono in un'area oggetto di
controllo della validità e della
sostenibilità di questa tecnica della
sicurezza anche di questa tecnica quindi
le zanzare sono e restano oggi un
problema enorme che interessa milioni di
persone
e purtroppo questi numeri secondo le
stime sono destinati sempre più ad
aumentare in un prossimo futuro
io sono un genetista molecolare e mi
occupo nel mio laboratorio presso il
dipartimento di biologia del nostro
ateneo dello studio di geni che possono
essere in qualche modo utilizzati per
migliorare la tecnica del in sesto
sterile per renderla più efficace e più
efficiente da qualche anno però ho
iniziato anche ad occuparmi di
dell'applicazione in campo di questa
metodica proprio per combattere le
zanzare per cercare di contribuire in
particolare ad un punto un aspetto
chiave che è proprio la partecipazione
di una comunità di una di una
cittadinanza che vive in un'area oggetto
di controllo sono infatti convinto che
come recita il celebre aforisma
attribuito a galileo galilei
dietro ogni problema ci sia una
opportunità partendo da questa
convinzione mi sono chiesto ma è
possibile trasformare la minaccia
costituita dalla zanzara in un'occasione
invece di sviluppo per le nostre
comunità locali
mi sono ispirato ad un antica arte
marziale l'aikido anch'essa di origine
asiatica proprio come la zanzara tigre
che si basa su riflettere contro
l'avversario l'energia stessa dei suoi
attacchi ho immaginato una popolazione
di zanzare che attacca è una comunità
che risponde anziché in modo individuale
in maniera collettiva o così ideato una
nazione ad alto impatto che mediante il
coinvolgimento di una comunità in un
progetto di prima ricerca e poi
controllo
un progetto quindi di citizen science in
cui le persone ci aiutano a produrre i
dati aiutano i ricercatori a produrre i
dati si possa arrivare non solo
all'eliminazione della zanzara ma anche
possa quest'azione possa fungere da
volano per lo sviluppo positivo della
comunità stessa
oggi infatti si parla sempre più spesso
dell'importanza di costruire delle
comunità forti che siano in grado di
affrontare le sfide del futuro e che
cosa c'è di meglio per raggiungere
questo risultato che far lavorare
insieme istituzioni e cittadini per un
comune obiettivo così importante come la
salute a tutela della salute pubblica e
per provare però a mettere in pratica
per passare dalla teoria alla pratica
avevamo bisogno di un posto un po
speciale con delle caratteristiche
particolari per cercare di mettere in
pratica l'azione un posto che avesse le
seguenti caratteristiche non troppo
piccolo ma neanche troppo grande per
poter è per poter essere facilmente
gestibile isolato per limitare l'effetto
di aree limitrofe non oggetto della
dell'azione dell'esperimento con un'alta
densità di zanzara tigre e con un'alta
densità umana simile diciamo a contesti
urbani
infine un posto magari anche bello
perché no in modo tale da rendere
piacevoli le attività da svolgere in
campo ci siamo un po interrogati e alla
fine abbiamo scoperto che un posto del
genere esisteva proprio nella nostra
regione ed è la bellissima isola di
procida che è molto vicina a dove ci
troviamo noi adesso
così abbiamo avviato una sperimentazione
quattro anni fa su quest'isola per
cercare di produrre i dati preliminari
che sono necessari per pianificare al
meglio i futuri rilasci di maschi
sterili per effettuare poi il test di
controllo vero e proprio per fare questo
occorre produrre dei dati che ci
permettono di rispondere a tre domande
quando rilasciare maschi sterili dove
rilasciarli sull'isola e in che numero
rilasciarli il primo passo del nostro
progetto e sa è consistito nel cercare
di coinvolgere l'amministrazione
dell'isola e siamo stati piacevolmente
sorpresi perché la risposta del sindaco
e della sua amministrazione è stata
molto molto positiva così con il loro
aiuto
abbiamo coinvolto un primo gruppo un
primo nucleo di dodici volontari alcuni
sono presenti in sala che ci hanno
aiutato a studiare nel tempo l'andamento
della popolazione di studiare la
dinamica temporale della zanzara
sull'isola mediante l'utilizzo di uno
strumento sofisticatissimo lodi trappola
che è questa qui
l'atto di plastica nero riempito d'acqua
con all'interno un foglietto di carta
l'acqua attira le femmine di zanzara
tigre che deporranno le uova su questo
foglietto che poi può essere facilmente
prelevato asciugato e si possono contare
le uova al microscopio la risposta della
gente nella delle persone dei nostri
volontari ma anche di tutti tutti gli
altri che ci hanno aiutato è stata
eccezionale perchè pensate che per un
anno abbiamo monitorato 30 posizioni 30
stazioni altrettante ovitrappole con
cadenza settimanale cioè non si
volontari ogni settimana prelevavano i
foglietti ce li facevano arrivare a
napoli
in realtà andavamo noi sull'isola
raccoglie le partecipano all'attività e
dalla bontà delle uova è stato possibile
scoprire che la zanzara tigre emerge a
procida nel mese di aprile fine marzo
inizio aprile e raggiunge un primo picco
di densità a luglio è un secondo a
settembre sempre utilizzando le
ovitrappole questa volta cento
distribuite su tutta l'isola e
coinvolgendo 80 famiglie che ci hanno
dato accesso alle loro case ei loro
giardini
abbiamo poi studiato la distribuzione
spaziale della zanzara sull'isola
individuando diversi hot spot delle aree
dove grazie a condizioni climatiche ed
ambientali favorevoli la zanzara
provincia la in maniera particolare a
settembre dell'anno scorso invece
abbiamo cercato di rispondere alla terza
domanda quante zanzare sarà necessario
in futuro rilasciare mediante
l'applicazione di una tecnica molto
divertente
nessuno di voi ha mai visto una zanzara
verde o una zanzara rosa credo
queste sono state marcate da noi sono
maschi marcati con una polvere
fluorescente ne abbiamo rilasciati
20.000 in un'area selezionata dell'isola
con l'aiuto dei nostri volontari e di
altre 30 famiglie
dopodiché abbiamo per me per due
settimane è proceduto alla ricattura ri
catturando chiaramente sia quelle
marcate da noi sia quelle già presenti
sull'isola facendo col nostro corpo da
esca e utilizzato un altro strumento
anch'esso molto sofisticato che questo
qui un aspiratore elettrico costruito
con una pentolina ed un tubo di
plexiglass con una rete alla base quindi
ci alzavamo il pantalone aspiravamo le
zanzare vi lascio immaginare come erano
ridotte le nostre gambe alla fine
dell'esperienza ma siamo riusciti a
prendere
il numero necessario di zanzare che
serviva e dal rapporto tra maschi
marcati con la polvere fluorescente e
maschi ricatturati invece selvatici è
stato possibile calcolare la densità per
ettaro di questo insetto sull'isola le
attività di settembre sono durante quel
periodo abbiamo anche pensato di
coinvolgere ulteriormente la popolazione
dell'isola con una una manifestazione
pubblica un attività divulgativa in
piazza organizzata nell'ambito della
notte europea dei ricercatori durante
questa attività
abbiamo in qualche modo permesso a tutte
le persone intervenute di sperimentare
in prima persona quello che stavamo
facendo nei loro giardini abbiamo
costruito un enorme gazebo con rete
abbiamo rilasciato maschi sterili
all'interno e tutti si sono esercitati a
fare catturatori di zanzare poi volevano
comprare gli aspiratori ma non glieli
abbiamo dati
e stata questa anche l'occasione di
entrare in contatto con gli studenti
delle scuole dell'isola che saranno i
protagonisti delle azioni che faremo
quest'anno a procida ci sono circa mille
studenti di scuole elementari e medie
abbiamo così pensato ad un progetto di
educazione ambientale per formare questi
ragazzi e per arrivare a tutte le
famiglie dell'isola in modo tale da
coinvolgere ciascuna famiglia in
attività di eliminazione degli habitat
larvali delle zanzare che come sapete le
zanzare hanno una fase della loro vita
che si svolge in acqua sono larghe e si
sviluppano nelle né gli accumuli che si
possono creare in un qualsiasi giardino
questa è una premessa fondamentale prima
di poter passare poi al rilascio di
maschi sterili ridurre al minimo i posti
dove le zanzare possano svilupparsi
quindi ne sappiamo che i bambini sono il
futuro di qualunque comunità
l'idea è quindi quella di formare i
bambini per farli diventare adulti
consapevoli ma anche educatori già da
subito degli adulti per costringerli a
fare delle azioni contro le zanzare da
subito questo progetto che va avanti da
quattro anni non è andato avanti senza
difficoltà come potete immaginare una di
queste per esempio è stata quella di
dover reperire le risorse per la ricerca
sapete che in italia questo è un
problema importante però noi abbiamo
deciso grazie all'aiuto della comunità
di procida che ci ha sostenuto di
iniziare subito anche senza avere tutte
le risorse necessarie proprio per
dimostrare che col loro aiuto
l'obiettivo di arrivare
il fondo che è quello che speriamo di
fare è possibile vorremmo poi usare la
tecnica dopo aver dimostrato la sua
sostenibilità è successo a procida anche
sulle altre isole campane di capri ed
ischia infine perché no sulla terraferma
abbiamo infatti un sogno che è quello di
fare della campania il primo posto al
mondo con un arcipelago a forte
componente turistica liberato dalla
minaccia delle zanzare con un sistema
con una tecnica eco sostenibile e
partecipata e siamo convinti che con la
partecipazione della società della
comunità a questo sia possibile
siamo inoltre convinti che la comunità
stessa alla fine del progetto si
riscoprirà diversa più forte e
consapevole perché avrà imparato ad
interagire perché avrà imparato a unire
le forze e le energie per un obiettivo
comune ma soprattutto perché avrà
imparato ad utilizzare la scienza e il
metodo scientifico fatto di osservazione
sperimenta sperimentale ed azioni logico
deduttive per migliorare la propria vita
e quella degli altri
a questo punto di solito alla fine di un
ted talks segue silenzio dell'oratore e
l'applauso della platea io mi auguro che
il mio rock vi sia piaciuto e in questo
caso vorrei che il vostro applauso non
va da solo a me ma a tutti i
collaboratori che ci hanno aiutato in
questi anni e alla comunità di procida
che ha accettato questa sfida collettiva
e che ci sta aiutando a rendere la
nostra idea realmente un'azione ad alto
impatto per il benessere della nostra
società grazie
[Applauso]